et on allait aborder le débordement ou
le dérapage plutôt de daniel bravo
c'était sublime sportes
on vous montre les images on en parle
juste après c'est le gros dérapage de la
semaine mercredi soir le consultant et
ancien joueur de l'agnel bravo commenté
sur bin sport la rencontre entre le
stade de reims et strasbourg
si sur le terrain tout s'est bien passé
avec une victoire des alsaciens 4 à 0
dans la cabine de commentateur c'est une
toute autre histoire
lors du temps additionnel de la première
période daniel bravo s'est permis un
commentaire plus que douteux diffusé à
l'antenne lors du but de l'attaquant
strasbourgeois mieux da costa
[Applaudissements]
cette décision
un jour
les réseaux sociaux se sont
immédiatement enflammé avec un
déferlement de messages suite à ses
propos choquants stéphane bahoken ancien
joueur au côté de nou yo yo si choqué a
posté à temps mais daniel bravo tu es
sérieux là avant de finalement supprimés
sont oui la chaîne consciente de
l'erreur de son journaliste s'est excusé
dans un message posté à l'issue de la
rencontre
son côté ninon da costa le joueur
incriminé ne semble pas en vouloir aux
journalistes il a écrit un message en
l'accompagnant d'une photo de lui et de
daniel bravo réalisé en coulisses à la
fin du match
et vous pensez-vous que daniel bravo
doit être sanctionné alors sanction pas
sanctions n'étaient pas les pancartes si
quelqu'un mais j'aime ça consternant
évidemment mère de gilles bon d'abord le
joueur est formidable sa réaction est
noble je précise juste avant ce que je
vais dire que daniel bravo c'est un ami
tant comme joueur que comme que sur ces
données bien dans le cas de gilles
verlant de préciser qu'il a un ami déjà
ils enlèvent et à il en a plus de talent
ici c'est un honneur de le dire oui donc
bien entendu c'est inacceptable mais je
le connais personnellement il n'est pas
raciste donc c'est un dérapage
moi je propose une sanction par exemple
un ou deux matches de suspension
d'antenne
voilà mais pas plus grave parce que je
sais que c'est un horrible lapsus voilà
si c'est là dessus ce qu'est ce qu'il a
voulu dire je veux bien qu'il soit
lapsus nancy cet appel alors non non non
alors franchement moi moi je le connais
un peu daniel bravo c'est effectivement
je vois pas ce gars on ira 16 ans il ne
les voilà qu'ils ont bafoué tous alors
franchement je suis quand tolérante sur
ces questions là ça me rend hystérique
et vraiment je ne pardonne rien pourtant
là franchement je suis sûr que c'est un
bafouillage un dérapage et je suis
convaincu qu'il n'est pas raciste
il ya des choses beaucoup plus
importantes à combattre dans le football
au niveau du racisme les cris de singe
voilà je vais dernière des choses
beaucoup plus graves
là c'est un lapsus il évidemment s'il
est puni on va pas crier au scandale
mais je ne pense pas que je suis
convaincu qu'ils ne paraissent alors le
visible
je te considère qu'il est plus grave
quand tu fais je remarque comme ça c'est
très grave je suis désolé c'est dit
il est parti de grave ne dis pas qu'il
ya plus grave parce qu'on entend des
cris de singe que ce soit des cris de
singe ou saas et au tangage magali à
résoudre et c'est grave a gagné a raison
parce que c'est parce que c'est daniel
bravo et c'est parce que c'est un bon
consultant et faciliter un bon joueur de
football on va dire ce qu'il en
réalisait pas raciste d'accord mais moi
je vous entends parler là tous il est
pas raciste il est pas raciste ça ne
s'en sort pas comme ça d'une bouche
comme ça par hasard d'abord on comprend
même pas pourquoi c'est sortir ce moment
là sur une histoire de 5 par 5 buts pour
un art c'est bien ou c'est que ça veut
dire quoi et vous avez déjà entendu
quelqu'un vous arrivez devant vous salut
je m'appelle berlin chez un [ __ ] de
raciste ça n'existe pas jamais personne
ne vous dira qu'il est raciste je suis
pas en train de dire qu'il est raciste
mais arrêtez de dormir j'ai déjà arrêté
de rire toi tu dit jamais deux cas moi
randy les conneries mais toto des non je
n'ai pas tout seul on attends attends je
viens d'enchaîner à athènes
je ne dis pas que j'ai déjà mais
donnerait à l'antenne mais bon quand tu
vois la raison frédéric il avait un
micro
on verra bien mais ce n'est pas la
première fois qu'ils aient des dérapages
ne oui vraiment non non c'est sait très
bien ce qu'il fait au moment où il dit
ça ça ressemble à une mauvaise blague ça
ressemble à une discussion peut-être
qu'il avait juste avant je pense que ça
ne dérape alphonse pâtissent pareil
c'est pas la vraie foi qui enverra pas
notamment dans les commentaires de foot
on en avait parlé il ya denis balmes un
cavenaghi va bien ou pas d'eau florale
main c'est une marque de fringues
ce qui n'a rien à voir très bien sa vie
son roman est une province et non
seulement faudrait qu'il soit raciste
mais en plus débile ce qui serait mieux
si les écouter c'est ainsi dit ça il va
se faire tuer donc à quoi ils le
diraient droit de saisine le dise mrhc
pas il était insurgé quand il ya des
gens qui font des blagues
alors c'est vrai que des fois ils font
les blacks fesses vous inchangé vous
êtes les premiers black fasse attention
c'est pas prêt à temps vous êtes en
premier quand il ya des blagues comme ça
quand griezmann let us à un black fait
qu'en griezmann n'avait fait ça blague
d'imiter un basketteur tout le monde est
monté au créneau pour dire ah faut pas
faire ça faut pas faire ça aya nakamura
pareil elle a dit à la gamine qu'il faut
pas faire ça d'accord tout sauf qu'à moi
la dia quinqua qu'il a dû de blanchir sa
peau un grand producteur qui fait défaut
que tu blanciste à pau parce qu'on
n'aime pas quand et à elle veut pas
donner le nom de ce mec-là faut aller
dans les deux sens là vous dites c'est
pas très grave
pour moi il faut qu'ils soient sans
frais
il a dit oui je peux pas dire non c'est
pas grave ce n'est pas raciste en route
je leur dit non tu suivais vachement
bien le goudron pour un noir mais je
suis pas raciste mais c'est pas alors on
va on va où on est tous d'accord c'est
même si seulement une mauvaise blague
belge s'est en tout cas c'est raté
on a créé en fait que ça donc je pense
que c'est désolant et c'est très
emmerdant de ce cadre